[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Corey Cleveland,
currently a senior.
I study electrical
engineering, and I
am the captain of the
ballroom dance team this year.
I started off when
I was a freshman.
And it was completely new to me.
I had never done any dancing.
I just saw them like
flying across the floor.
You know it was hard
not to get infected.
And I was like, I want to be
able to do this and present
this myself.
As well as give this
to other people.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It's amazing because humans have
like this small imperceptible
ability to pick up on each
other's body language.
And so I can talk to
the audience that way.
Even more so, I
have an opportunity
to communicate with my partner.
And there's this like such an
intimate and deep connection
with another person.
That's really what I enjoy.